boa tarde a todos antes mas muito
obrigado a organização pelo convite
é com muito prazer que estou aqui hoje
dez anos depois porque foi há dez anos
que o parque vila real e foi portanto
postulante deve trabalhar mas foi aqui
passarem bons anos da minha vida eu
enfiei a enologia pela universidade de
trás-os-montes e alto douro
e como bom filho à casa torna eu estou
aqui e é com grande prazer tanto eu sou
coimbra mas foi aqui que estudar e foi
aqui como essência enologia e como vocês
devem imaginar trabalho é em vinhos do e
portanto a minha vida gira à volta do
vinho as visitas diárias mas quando eu
canto o vevo e portanto não sofram sobre
a minha profissão de novo
é uma posição ainda um pouco
desconhecida por grande parte da
sociedade
ontem foi um dia muito fluído para vila
real que tivemos um encontro de antigos
alunos denúncia voltar que foi brilhante
então grande parte da população começa a
perceber o que é que o animal faz mas
ainda havia dúvidas e portanto preparar
um único sonho da minha apresentação pra
falar um pouco sobre a profissão de noll
e então é como é que as pessoas vêem o
enólogo e as opiniões
a variedade de opiniões os meus amigos
que não trabalham no ramo do vinho
conduzir o que sou e novo e os pensam
que minha vida é mais ou menos assim é o
rega voz fluviário é ver e contar
histórias gritar brindes levar e pronto
depois há uma parte grande da sociedade
que pensa que a minha vida de que vida
de novo é mais ou menos isto bobeira eu
não sei dizer que a menina fazer xixi
pra te ver fazer xixi ver que me
interessa é de papéis na vida santa
pagam tito velas e não sei que era bom
que fosse assim mas não é
depois
ainda é o que como eu como a minha
família ver profissão de 9v um bom
trabalho que pensam que eu sou quase
jesus cristo que zerou o filho a um copo
d'água mão por filho entre também não é
não é bem assim
depois ao carro ao caminho camisinha
pensa que o que eu faço uma vez provamos
que eu fazia de 2009 que está em
trabalho convincente e tal fato já pelo
próprio de estações não é sensorial e
portanto dos 20 trabalhe drogas e homens
mas já desconfiava que você pois aquilo
que eu tento dizer que faça o que é um
enorme portanto é uma pessoa que serve
todo o processo de produção do vinho
desde a plantação da vinha até a vindima
a verificação aprova tudo isso e depois
ao que vem fácil que é muitos papais
muitas horas no diretório e na altura da
vindima trabalho duro dos teus 14 horas
por dia
um abraço a profissão de novembro um
estimulante mas não é assim tão
romântica como muitos pensam
vou continuar agora a minha apresentação
falarmos um cravinho do que eu faço e
sou um novo trabalho uma parte da
produção mas grande parte do tempo à
investigação científica na parte das
vinhas e do vinho que eu faço isso faço
isso porque o vim pra mim
antes de mais é uma coisa bastante
importante não é apenas uma vida tanto
vinho e vinho como o bem estar são é que
em portugal o vinson dois mil anos de
história no mundo são sete mil anos de
história
o vinho é sinónimo do progresso
um fala por exemplo da subseção também
votar no egípcio fenícia e depois mais
tarde a civilização greco romana a qual
nós somos herdeiros e eu vos a vós todos
como orgulho trazemos essas coisas tão
boas que essa civilização nos trouxe e
inclusiva o vinho
portanto o vinho o vinho é qualquer
coisa muito especial para mim e para
muitos gostam amanhã acredito e em todo
mundo vem até visto como algo espiritual
nos rituais judaicos cristãos ainda hoje
utilizamos o vinho nas suas operações
o ponto que compararmos e num
capitalizarmos o vinho enquanto sandy de
deus e quando numa missa
tomamos a ost vemos o vinho o vinho é o
sangue de terra até a 3 nos deu
portanto agora para voltar um pouco
é porque eu faço isto tal está vendo
vocês já perceberam os desafios do hoje
em dia do enólogo e um produtor vinho
vinhos é fazer o vinho cada vez melhor e
produzir o vinho condições com mais
respeito às possíveis para o ambiente e
portanto que o vin seja 11 sinônimo de
produto saltar e é isso que eu faço eu
tenho feito nos últimos nos últimos anos
da minha vida eu deixei vila real em
2005 e portanto fui com a minha maior
cartão até frança e lá estou são dez
anos só que estou a trabalhar e hoje o
que eu gostava de partilhar convosco era
nem a experiência enquanto parte de uma
geração que teve que deixar o país e
estrangeiro como você chave portugal não
exporta petróleo transporta pessoas e
das boas mas não vou falar por mim mas
grande parte dos meus dois mil dos
sonhos da minha geração tiveram portanto
que sair do país e nós encontramos em
uma situação em que a sociedade investiu
durante os últimos 20 ou 30 anos
formar pessoas nas várias áreas e depois
essas pessoas e se esforçou não é
aproveitável grande parte não é
aproveitado no país é aproveitar por
outros países que já são hits com mais
de frança 776 ficam todos contentes e
nós fazemos a parte que toda damos o vôo
e os legal e portanto o que eu gostava
de propor peculiar um cara balança e
também podemos aproveitar portugalo
países que estão aproveitaram cada
esforço todo foi posto em nós gera são
português estava fora era possamos todos
portugueses que estão lá fora e
portugueses que estão cá dentro
fazer lá se faz é fazer conexões trocar
experiências fazer parcerias fazer
projetos fazer acontecer coisas
trabalhar juntos
quais são as vantagens como português
que está lá fora o empresário portuguesa
prof seja qual for o ramo trabalho lá de
trabalhar com o português estão cá
dentro
a primeira é que pronto é um prazer
pessoal trabalhar com patriota segundo a
segunda mais pragmática é que sabemos
que conhecemos a capacidade de trabalho
e de fazer coisas portuguesas que é
realmente é excecional portanto da nossa
parte do dia estão lá fora ganha temos
essas duas vantagens
os portugueses que estão cá dentro que
eles podem ganhar em trabalhar com o
português que estão lá fora nós podemos
ser os embaixadores do melhor que se faz
cá em portugal da capacidade trabalhos
português das competências
técnico-científicas profício
profissionais e assim atrair atenção
investimento e trabalhar produzir e
fazer acontecer a acontecer coisas eu
acho que é muito importante e é isso que
eu proponho a todos todos vocês
conseguiram consigo estar todos juntos
português que estão lá fora e
portuguesas estão cá dentro
em portugal o nosso país é muito mais
não correto um retângulo zinho à beira
mar plantado
somos milhões e desde há cinco séculos
que andamos a espalhar a portugalidade e
então portanto hoje a mensagem que você
queria deixar era que possamos fazer
coisas e e portugal seja uma arma de
construção massiva e é ter um problema